all right the strip is open and the
possibilities are
limitless right you'll see what i did
there in a second let's welcome back to
the show sleight of hand artist shin lim
the star of limitless at the mirage my
guy how are you i haven't seen you since
it's been a while it's been so long how
you doing
i'm good i'm good how are you i'm doing
well we're so excited to have you back
on stage so tell us about the new show
i'm sure you had plenty of time to come
up
with ideas and learn new tricks what can
we expect
yeah well in uh i guess during during
quarantine i was
put in a creative isolation so i've been
creating a lot of
new experimental concepts and i can't
wait to share it with the world it's uh
it's really really cool stuff
it's all completely brand new even if
you've seen the show before
if you watch it again it's gonna feel
completely different
well i got the opportunity to sit down
with you on stage at the mirage and you
just blew my mind so i still remember
that
you remember that that was so much fun
it was so much fun one of my favorite
things i've ever done on this show so
far um
but let's educate everybody on what a
sleight of hand artist
is and what they can expect from you in
particular and what you do
yeah i mean it's a lot like how you
would see a pianist
play during a concert or you know in the
ballroom or whatever
you know their fingers are moving so
fast and that they are
creating what seems to be uh mute like
magic you know it feels like magic but
it's really just music and so i'm doing
the same thing with
everyday objects the deck of cards coins
whatever you know i'm not claiming to
have any sort of supernatural powers or
anything takes a lot of dexterity and
takes a lot of uh a lot of time and
patience so
definitely a talent um and you mentioned
piano you did play piano and that's kind
of how you
started your passion for this right
oh yeah yeah i uh i i started off in
piano in university and then
uh i actually got carpal tunnel in both
of my wrists
so i had to kind of make a tough
decision
essentially i was using my hands too
much i was
uh because side of hand with magic takes
a lot of time and
practice and so does the piano equally
yeah and so the doctor was
pretty much saying i i had to drop one
two was too much
and so i kind of took a leap of faith
i chose magic and i crossed my fingers
and i said i hope this one's it
right i think it's working out for you
and i think i think you're doing great
um so let's get to the trick because i
know naturally it's time to blow our
minds right
sure sure sure i have something prepared
it's it's simple it isn't
it's not [ __ ] very simple since
you're not here physically it's gonna be
a little bit uh not as impressive but i
hope it's still good so i have a pick up
cards over here
uh and and you're gonna take a card okay
but uh
virtually so you just say whatever card
you like that you see you just
if i'm not spreading the cards let's do
it let's do the queen of hearts the
queen of hearts
queen of hearts yeah all right we'll do
the queen okay that's a good card
all right so we'll take the queen of
hearts and then we'll do something that
you've seen before
uh we can take the queen of hearts right
and it's about i would say
halfway into the deck right you've seen
this one before because
the queen goes from the middle and i
just snap my hands and the queen can go
right down to the bottom
of the deck right and if i shake my hand
like this the queen can also jump from
the bottom straight to the top
and it's no longer in the bottom you see
this is all this is all just
manipulating the cards
that's all it is right and and here's
something that will make it a lot more
difficult but rocky so watch this okay
if i can take the deck half of it is
face up and half of its face down
see this is going to make it a lot more
difficult
we're going to do something called the
pharaoh shuffle i don't know if you've
heard of that
well you live in vegas you might know so
it's pretty much every single card is
being shuffled face up into face down
equally
one card after the other like this
yeah and then we'll place your queen
into the deck randomly i
i really don't know where it is now and
i'm going to continuously shuffle this
mess essentially and you just say stop
at any point
that you want russia i'll put it up to
you stop
right here yeah okay you want me to keep
going all right
all right so so the deck is still still
very much mixed as you can see over here
right face up face down this is what we
call a uh
chaos that's essentially it and and that
makes things really difficult for
magicians but
if i can just fix every single card
see it was face up face down right you
saw the card yeah
this happened slowly this happened very
slowly but now
bit by bit you can notice the cards
actually start to just
yeah all except for the queen of hearts
okay and look at every single card no
not really really
every single card except for the queen
makes
no sense it makes no sense
wow it must be a lucky card though so
that's why
we'll take it then we'll take that's our
lucky card here in las vegas now thank
you shin
you you are amazing and i'm so excited
to finally see the show myself everyone
at home is so excited
where can people get tickets and more
information uh at the mirage
at the mirage or at shinlandmagik.com uh
you can search it up it's uh
the the link is right there so it's in
vegas it's at the mirage theater 7 30
p.m every night
i believe it's from thursday to monday
and then we have two days
well we are excited welcome back to the
stage thank you so much
thank you so much all right we'll be
right back